I was a Kine addict for probably around
about 10 11 years and um for me that had
Dreadful effects I nearly lost my
bladder um my kidneys my liver almost
packed in I lost half my body weight at
the time which I went down to around
about six Stone um but to be honest it
that wasn't K's fault that was my
[Music]
fault my name is Thomas I'm a public
speaker I'm also a student and I'm also
a recovering drug addict and I'm here
today to answer the audience questions
regarding drug abuse all the taboo and
scary questions that we have but
probably don't um have the courage to
ask in
public okay so the first
question what was the first hit like or
what was that first hit
like so I remember very well my first um
encounter with cocaine so a bunch of
friends that I'll not mention for
obvious reasons um they were all a bit
older than me all deemed as really cool
confident guys um and I had I was really
naive never tried drugs never even seen
cocaine at this point apart from my own
Telly or whatever and I had no idea how
to take it I had no idea how much to
take I genuinely thought I was going to
die I was really scared and all weird
about it and um my friend put a straw in
a bag and said like you know put your
nose over it and have a you know have a
little sniff and and that's how you do
it um so the first time I tried it I
actually rather than snorting in I I
blew out through my nose and blew cook
in everywhere which off my friends um so
they let me have another go um and they
put the straw back in the bag in another
bag and um I probably snorted about half
a gram in one go um and I instantly felt
this like shock all the way like from my
head to the bottom of my spine and
instantly I felt like I was more um I
felt like I was more present I felt like
I was more aware of time my environment
the space that I was in um as well as
feeling this euphoric Rush of being like
loved up with everything and anyone and
that you know I felt really good about
myself which is the first time in a long
time that I actually felt like that and
um you know and that needs to where you
are starting cocaine before you go to
work um because you need it because
you've been up for weeks on end but
weirdly enough I think when you're young
you're quite naive and you glamorize
those sort of stupid moments um you know
you all think it's cool being dragged
out of a nightclub and you know it's
funny and it's a laugh um but you know
the reality is that it's not um and it
should definitely be seen as a huge you
know a huge cause for concern what was
the most you spend on drugs in a
day God um
so weirdly enough um I used I grew up in
London and I used to live in London
during my sort 18s early 20s and one of
my friends who is actually still a very
good friend of mine today um he came
down to visit me and I think over the
course of the weekend we went out and at
this point I didn't take camine um my
addiction was cocaine and um between us
we probably spent around about seven
Grand over the course of a week possibly
£8,000 that was on a Friday and Saturday
sort of filtering on in into the Sunday
um so in a day um not too sure but over
the course of a weekend nearly £10,000
between two of us so it's quite a lot um
and I've probably spent way way way way
more in my
life what is a khole um so I can answer
this really easily uh so k a khole is
what people call it is a is when you
take too much ketamine and you sort of
trip power into a into another place in
the universe um it's also probably where
you're most vulnerable to an attack or
to any sort of any abuse that you may
have at a party or you may experience a
kettle is is something that a lot of I
think users try and seek to gain
whatever pleasure it is that they gain
from it um but it's also an incredibly
dangerous um position or point in your
life to being and also I've been in um
thousands of kettles um and I never
enjoyed any single one of
them what was the most you used in a day
um
so the worst I was the worst I can
recall of using a day was was ironically
the last 24 hours um before I went into
reab um and I sniffed a total of 36
grams of ketamine uh within a 24-hour
period And there's probably people
watching that would think he chatting
Absol
um but that is the God's honest truth um
but that was at the height of my
addiction where I was snorting um
anything upwards of announced today uh
from morning till night until I passed
out um which is also why I weighed six
Stone and was nearly
dead so why did you take K in the first
place um well I had a very traumatic
childhood I went through things that um
you wouldn't wish upon your worst enemy
I saw a lot of domestic violence abuse a
lot of things that would um that made me
have a lot of insecurities and feel
really about myself um and for me
although I'd taken cocaine and I took
acid for you know I tried pills and all
these other sorts of drugs uh for me
camine just made my brain go numb it
shut out all the negative voices in my
head or for a period of time anyway and
um for me it just helped get through the
day try know sounds quite cheesy um but
it did and for me you know I was I was
scared to take care of me in the first
time time I tried it and I never really
felt it cuz I mixed it with cocaine and
then once I tried it on its own um I
instantly fell in love with that feeling
of just not caring about anything or
arguing with myself in my head
constantly um there's a lot of theories
on what causes addiction um whether it's
lifestyle habits whether it's your
environment whether it's your attitudes
or or lots of there's lots of different
factors that makes up um someone's
decision to choose drugs But ultimately
I think what underlines it is pain um is
trauma is aces adverse childhood
experiences for those that don't know
the acronym um but for me it's it's all
about trauma to me addiction is the
answer to solve all of your problems um
or it was for a very long period of my
life which drug has the worst effect on
you um I was a chamine addict for
probably around about 10 11 years um and
um for me that had Dreadful effects I
nearly lost my bladder um my kidneys my
liver almost packed in I lost half my
body weight at the time which I went
down to around about six Stone um but to
be honest it that wasn't ketamine's
fault that was my fault and also you
know that drug quite easily could have
been alcohol or crack or cocaine or or
smack it could have been any other drug
um but for me it was you know my my
choice was was to choose um ketamine
which has profound effects um and a lot
of them are quite embarrassing so for
example like I would pass your when I
when I would go to the toilet I would
pass chunks of which I later found out
was chunks of the lining of my bladder
which sounds absolutely disgusting so if
you're eating whilst watching this I
apologize um but I used to blood chunks
I used to pass out um the thing with
ketamine is your bladder naturally
expands and contracts to control the the
flow of urine when you go to the toilet
from your bladder um but what ketamine
does is it actually sticks to the lining
of your bladder it's scars it so what it
does is then it prevents your bladder
from expanding and Contracting and it
also what it does is it damages the
nerve endings which constantly sends the
signal to your brain that you need the
toilet so if you speak to any ketamine
addict for example one of the things
that they won't talk about in public but
they all probably slightly talk about to
each other is the fact that you have
severe severe problems um downstairs
going to the toilet passing urine is
unbelievably painful um and you don't
pee like how you should pee you pee
little drops and that might take you an
hour and you were screaming on the floor
and all over yourself um it is
disgusting but I've got friends that are
my age in the 30s even maybe 40s that um
that even need to wear a bag or more
embarrassingly um where nap is you can
imagine being 36 six years old um into a
nappy um and I'm not saying that to you
know to to make you know to make a joke
of people that do that but that's how
serious it is um if you continue to use
camine it will it will destroy your body
um and that not that's not to mention
the Mental effects you know what is the
closest you came to dying and I I
remember being in hospital only a few
weeks before I went into riab and I was
telling the doctor you know I've got
issues you know I can't stop taking
drugs blah blah blah um and he said
regardless of the drugs if you don't eat
you are going to die um because you are
malnourished your body is physically
shutting down towards the end of my
addiction you know I lost so much weight
I was so ill um I was so depressed and
just mentally physically spiritually and
mentally um and I was quite happy to die
as well which is which is the
frightening thing in it all um I
actually thought that death would be the
final thing that that would release the
pain and suffer but thankfully you know
that didn't happen um I managed to sort
it out so I was lucky in that aspect but
yeah that was definitely the closes that
I came came to death and I'll never go
back
there so next question is should all
drugs be
legalized so I've had this conversation
loads of times before there is countries
such as Portugal where would be a great
example of where the the government
legalized drugs what that doesn't mean
is that you could walk to your local
Marx expenses and buy cocaine or crack
or ketamine or any other drug that you
want what it did do was it legalized um
so Portugal for example they did was
they legalized the possession of drugs
so if you got caught with a certain
amount rather than being punished and
going through sort of the judicial
system um and going to prison or getting
a criminal record which would be held
against you and also add further stigma
and um discrimination I guess to the
person what they did was they legalized
it so if you did get caught with drugs
with possession um unless obviously it
was a huge vast amount where you
obviously dealing drugs you would um be
offered support and help um which is an
amazing idea um so in that respect yes
it should be our drug laws are well
outdated as well um and I live in
Scotland where the drug laws are
actually governed by West Minister and
not Scotland itself which causes an
array of massive problems as well
considering that Glasgow in particular
where I live is the drug capital of
Europe so it's it's difficult to tackle
drug problems when you're governed by
another country um in this case
Scotland so what's riab like um so I can
I can tell you from firstand experience
I went to riab on the 2nd of November
2018 and never looked back really but um
riab is hard um everyone's crazy in a
nice way um there's a lot of people that
have got severe issues there's a lot of
people with a lot of trust issues with
commitment issues with how they fit into
society and how they even fit in or feel
within themselves um reab is hard you
know I never went to a posh fancy reab
um sorry if anyone from the reab that
works for the RAB that I went to it's an
amazing facility um I went to a place
called Phoenix Futures in in Glasgow in
Scotland um it was incredibly
challenging it was difficult some days I
wanted to kill myself like not literally
but like it was so difficult that um it
was hard to cope in there sometimes but
the staff were amazing um certain
members of staff anyway
um it it's hard um I'm not going to lie
riab shouldn't be seen as a holiday
Resort it's not somewhere you going and
practice yoga for six months and and hug
trees and come out and everything's
going to be off you know okay you can do
those things um I don't agree with
medicine being used and also I think I
was the only person that the reab that I
went to ever heard of refusing to detox
so when I went to riab um I refused all
the other drugs that they were going to
they give me to come off a ketamine so
um there's there's a ton of
pharmaceutical drugs that they can give
you to detox and I was the only person
that the doctor had ever heard in her 40
years of practice that refused to detox
so I went Cold Turkey um in my
experience it's about stopping taking a
step back looking at what needs to be
fixed in in your own self and your soul
um and that doesn't make me better
doesn't make me different
um it's just me that's what I wanted to
do um that's because that's what I
believe was best for
me so what's the worst what's the worst
part about being Queen
um God uh so I would say the worst part
is but it's also the it's the worst part
but in hindsight also one of the best
parts is the fact that rather than
running away from my problems I tackle
them head on
um which can be very difficult at times
times very very difficult um in some
cases but rather than running away from
our problems and going and using drugs
to deal with them all I'd rather tackle
the the problem holistically or at least
have a method of approaching a certain
thing that I need to resolve and get it
resolved and you know it takes a lot of
confidence it takes a lot of resilience
to do things like that um I think one of
the also the one thing that's just came
to my mind one of the worst Parts about
being
clean is the fact that when you are
cleaning sober you realize how up the
rest of the world is um and how sorry am
I allow to swear um but yeah you realize
you know how up Society is um you know
I'm not perfect I'm not a saint you know
I'm not um walking around like Jesus
Christ and I'm the purest Soul on the
planet you know I'm I'm flawed like
every other human being but um I think
when you're cleaning sober you realize
how much Society depends on substances
to avoid life um and that's quite a
daunting thought to have um so yeah
those things are the worst so what was
the worst thing you did on drugs this is
a dreaded question um because there's
there's loads of things that I did
um I stole money um I borrowed money
from people with all intentions of
paying them back and and probably never
did for years um I would use drugs in
front of not directly in front of my
family um but I would you know I'd say
I'm going to the toilet which wasn't an
unusual thing um and I've been there for
half an hour racking lines up um you
know and then I'd come out in a sort of
not quite a cat All State but also not
really on this planet either um and lie
about it you know I've got I've got a
beautiful family and you know I've got
like a I've got a son now which
thankfully he'll never ever ever see
that person but my nephew has um my two
nieces fortunately they weren't born
then either they've been born during um
during the time I I managed to get into
recovery and and and now um but my
nephew did you know and and I feel you
know I feel awful for that um I feel
awful for all the times that my mom used
to see me and you know there was a part
of that that I used to I used to enjoy
seeing I used to want my mom to see me
like that because used to blame my mom
for so many things and and the truth is
you know my mom wasn't responsible for
me taking drugs I was
um you know there's there's loads of
there's loads of things I did on drugs
and I'm not going to blame it and say oh
it was the drugs it it was me it was
me so what is the thing you miss most
from your time as an
addict
um
I think the the most thing that I've
missed which is probably quite deep and
philosophical is the fact that I missed
the time that I wasted um I missed the
time that
I wasted waiting for drugs ordering
drugs buying drugs selling drugs
collecting drugs dropping drugs off
waiting for hours for people to meet me
when I was really really um at death
story in my addiction I you know all the
arguments I used to have with drug
dealers if I laid stuff on and not paid
them back or money had borrowed off
friends and family to pay drug dealers
and all of the chaos and that addiction
offers um I don't miss any of that but I
do miss the time wasted doing all those
things if you know if there's one thing
you can't ever get back is time um and
unfortunately I've got loads of friends
that have unfortunately lost their lives
to addiction and they're completely out
of time um but that's the thing I regret
the
most Are you ashamed of your past
um it's a really good question I used to
be um I used to be ashamed of my past
when I first went into treatment when I
first went into rehab and I used to
think about all the damage that I did to
my friends my family the community that
I lived in and also all the damage I did
to myself and my loved ones more
importantly um but now I like to think
I've I've turned that negative into a
positive I talk to thousands of people
across the country and hopefully I can
make a difference and more importantly
challenge a stigma that surrounds
addiction so I use my
past to to be the person I am
today so can anyone become addicted if
they try drugs
um yeah of course anyone can go through
pain and suffering and anybody can go
through um you know dark and terrible
times anybody can be affected through
their mental health or the world around
them um and a lot of people will turn to
drugs as a solution you get a lot of
people as well which probably isn't
talking about enough is the fact that
people do get addicted to all sorts of
pharmaceutical drugs so not all drug
addicts you know are out there taking
crack or smack or ketamine um you
there's a lot of normal people that will
take um pharmaceutical drugs that are
just equally as dangerous as the other
drugs that I've just mentioned um so
anybody has the potential to to be
become a drug addict um and in the same
respect anybody has the potential to
stop being a drug addict as well do you
think there's a drug that's the most
addictive I don't personally think it's
just one drug over the other and if
anything the probably the most common
drug that's used every single day that
I've seen you numerous times on my way
here is alcohol but no one ever talks
about that because that's illegalized
drugs we pay tax on it and it's not you
know it's socially acceptable if pubs
sold crack maybe that might be you know
maybe people might view it differently
then but um but yeah alcohol would
probably be the most common how would
you start a conversation with someone to
tell them to think that they're
addicted now that's probably the most
difficult but also simplest um or I'll
probably it's the most simplest thing
that anybody can do any human being can
do to another which is sit down and and
and truly listen to them now the problem
is that unfortunately the addict may not
always tell you what's going on um they
may tell you a degree a certain amount
you know to a point um but ultimately
what we want there there's a famous
quote that says the opposite addiction
is connection uh which I think is a guy
called Joan Harry an amazing guy um that
studies addiction and and all the the
things linked to it um and I think all
we really want when I was in addict was
to connect um I felt like I didn't
belong anywhere I felt like I didn't
belong in society and the community that
I was in even in the world I didn't F I
didn't feel like I was even a part of my
own family um I didn't want to exist
anymore so for me having someone sit
down and say you know what is going on
um and not in a you know not in a Brash
or confrontational way um just saying it
with love um and for me you know if I
wasn't asked that question I wouldn't be
here today um so if you know someone you
know Sit Them Down create a safe space
don't shout it out on the streets in
public or screaming shout at someone in
a nightclub if off the red have it in a
safe and comfortable environment where
you can sit that individual down or
group and say you know do not think this
is a problem um ask them why they think
they do it they may not admit it
straight away but I think internally it
will get them sort of critically
thinking about their lives and what
they're doing um and it starts as simple
as asking someone if they're okay and
genuinely meaning it when you're in
addiction you are isolated you were
cutting yourself off from every
relationship to any meaningful
Communications with people any
connection whatsoever and then it's like
oh I wonder why I'm drinking myself to
death or using myself or doing whatever
to death and it's like cuz what else
have you got going on